[Music]
and haitious cause of death has been
revealed
the actress died on Friday following her
fiery car crash the LA County coroner's
office confirms the details to ET and
died from smoke inhalation and thermal
injuries due to the crash
the news comes just days after Anne was
taken off life support a decision made
after a compatible person was found to
receive her donated organs which is
something Ann wanted I would say to
anybody you know go for what you feel
truthfully in your life and you will be
rewarded a million fold following the
crash we learned and suffered a severe
brain injury significant Burns and lung
damage in the wake of Anne's passing I
just want to say a few things Anne's
first husband Coley lafoon mourned in on
Instagram they shared an adult son 20
year old Homer she was Brave and
fearless loved really hard goodbye Anne
love you thank you thank you for all the
good times there were so many and um see
you on the other side and there's new
insight from a chilling 9-1-1 call
what's the emergency there a car just
went through my neighbor's house so that
the car went all the way into the house
yes
like 10 feet into the house a neighbor
placed a call around 10 55 a.m and it
took more than five minutes for help to
arrive is he awake can you find out if
the patient's awake is a patient
the house is on fire now
what part of the car is smoking
what what is smoking it's a lot of
smoking it's big enough it's um so it's
a car catching on fire
yes
okay okay
get everybody out of the house can you
get that driver out of the car
no well
is there anybody touching the car
yeah if there's somebody touching the
car yeah so yes because somebody is
trapped in the car